these people mean business for weeks
members of the special task force have
been observing the house of a suspected
trafficker today they're going to pounce
the atmosphere is tense with Solomon Oh
kudu WA is reassuring for him and the
team this is now routine in the last few
months they've arrested 30 human
traffickers
are you prepared for all eventualities
so that nothing will go wrong because
when even quality there were officers
and we have here know what to do they
are fully prepared for the operation
today
the state governor has set up the task
force and made Solomon special advisor
he has first-hand experience of what
it's like to spend years in Libya trying
to survive he came back six years ago
determined to take up the fight against
human trafficking
[Music]
yeah because of the experience on Hart
in Libya when I was a Libya
this human treatments be better than our
Nigerian girls and boys and uh please
something to write to my god that is my
one of my motivation we close in on the
suspects house the operation begins
obviously identified the trafficker in
the next minutes will be crucial for the
operation bad luck the suspects not at
home maybe he got a tip-off still the
task force did arrest a woman who
probably belongs to the network but she
seems to be at the bottom of the
hierarchy a so-called recruiter who gets
paid for luring in young girls most of
the time we go for the bigger guys but
in case we do not have much information
about the big guys will go for the
lesser guys to help us
[Music]
for years Benin City and southern
Nigeria has had a reputation as a center
for human trafficking
it used to be mainly young women who
were smuggled into Europe to work as
prostitutes
more recently the human traffickers have
expanded the network also in Libya many
migrants are held captive there and have
to work as slaves or pay a ransom North
African and Nigerian bands work hand in
hand Solomon had hoped that the arrest
of the recruiter would help the task
force get the names of the big fish but
the woman stubbornly remained silent the
best tips the team told us usually come
from former victims for some time now
Nigeria has been expanding its program
for returning migrants most of them
first stay in this former hotel in Benin
City Solomon questions a group were
flown out of Libya just a few days ago
he often has to be an investigator and a
psychologist at the same time one of the
women still has the dry bread she was
given in the traffickers hideout
they will ask you to pay dolla to eat
chips with this name I should paid to
Egypt true Western our money grant and
they will beat you for it if you refused
to pay the money don't kill men women
children they do die so please we are
begging for the survivors to rescue
those one-night stands still in Libya so
bring them back home please for Solomon
and his team a tiring day comes to an
end they're proud of their work but they
know the most difficult part still lies
ahead it's unclear whether the thousands
of disillusioned and traumatized
returnees will find new hope back home
or if they'll just leave again but
Solomon is determined to carry on until
the last human trafficker in Benin City
is caught
[Music]